ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
POWER QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM TALLIED DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY
LEE LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
NGUYEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES LOOSE REEBOKS ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH. STONE
TEEN CALAVERAS BE APPROVED WHILE
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER. WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN MISTER. IN THE NAME OF GOD
. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. GOD OF ALL GRACE BE
WITH US NOW AND UNTIL THE END.
YOU KNOW EACH OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS ASSEMBLY. YOU HAVE GIVEN
EACH DIFFERENT GIFTS. NOT
TOGETHER THEY MAY ACHIEVE YOUR
PURPOSE. AND BRING ABOUT LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU HAVE
CALLED THEM FORCE FROM DIFFERENT
PLACES. AND ASSEMBLE THEM IN
THIS CHAMBER. TO SERVE THIS
GREAT STATE AND SHAPE ITS FUTURE
. GIVE THEM VISION ROOTED IN
FAITH ATTENTIVE LISTENING TO THE
NEEDS OF THE TIMES AND
DISCERNING MARKS. TO MAKE RIGHT
JUDGMENTS. GOD OF ALL GRACE BE
WITH US NOW AND FOREVER I MEAN.
THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOARD AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
BOARD. MEMBER FIFTIES OR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART READY BEGIN.
DILIGENCE. AMERICA. ZERO YEARS
AGO JUSTICE FOR OUR- THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO MONDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE SUMMIT AT ONE PM
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE EVASIVE THE
PRESIDING CHEAPER TO PROGRAM THE
TEST REFLECTIVITY BOWMAN READING
WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS CALLED
PROPERLY SIMPLY CONSERVE MEMBER
COURT. RACIALLY MOVES AND MISTER
FLORA SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF-COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CALDERON QUIRK AND GRAYSON FOR
MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
OUR QUE HAN. FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY.
WHAT WOULD YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DAVIES AND CHOI
TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
BIRTHDAYS THIS WEEK. TODAY IS
REPUBLICAN LEADER GALLAGHER'S
BIRTHDAY WHEN YOU SEE HIM PLEASE
WISH HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY. AND
WEDNESDAY MARCH NINTH IS
ASSEMBLY MEBER SMITH'S BIRTHDAY
. HAPPY BIRTHDAY SIR. MEMBERS WE
HAVE A VERY LIGHT FILE TODAY. WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SHALL BE
CONTINUED. MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD FILE ITEM NUMBER TO PASS A
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE ACR ONE FORTY SIX BY MS
GARCIA. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA RELATIVE TO
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK.
MISTER SEA AT EMAIL THANK YOU
MEMBERS AS CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMAN'S CAUCUS I AM PROUD TO
AUTHOR ACR ONE FORTY SIX WHICH
IN PLANES MARCH SEVENTH THAT SEE
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK. THIS
RESOLUTION CELEBRATES WOMEN
AFTER A CRUCIAL PART OF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND SEEKS
TO ENCOURAGE POLICYMAKERS AND
INDUSTRIES TO ADOPT POLICIES
THAT WILL SUCCESSFULLY INCREASED
WOMAN AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
. ACR ONE FORTY SIX ALSO SEEKS
TO ELIMINATE THE NUMEROUS
DISPARITIES LIMON FAITH IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. BY
RAISING AWARENESS OF GENDER
INEQUITIES WOMEN COMPROMISED
COMPRISE ONLY 6% OF APPRENTICES
AND UNDER 10% OF CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY- AT THE START OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE. ALTHOUGH
THEY MAKE UP 47% OF THE US
POPULATION TODAY. TODAY FOR
EVERY FIVE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
WHO ARE PREPARING FOR RETIREMENT
THERE'S ONLY ONE IN THE PIPELINE
TO REPLACE THEM. ACR ONE FORTY
SIX AND RECOGNIZES WOMEN F. AN
UNTAPPED RESOURCE TO HELP CLOSE
THE SKILLED LABOR GAP TO THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO KEEP
PACE WITH AND INFRASTRUCTURAL
NEEDS. WE ARE GOING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND STABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS YOU MUST
EDUCATE AND INSPIRE PEOPLE ABOUT
THE REWARDING CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES IN CONSTRUCTION
AND THE TRAITS WITHOUT STUDENT
LOAN DEBTS AND THAT INCLUDES
WOMEN. CONVINCING WOMEN THEY CAN
THRIVE IN CONSTRUCTION AND THAT
THE TRADES WILL TREAT THEM WELL
REPRESENTS A SHIFT IN THE
MINDSET THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT. IT TAKES TIME AND
ADVOCACY AND OF COURSE
PERSISTENCE. ACR ONE FORTY SIX
HOUSES BUILD AWARENESS AND
EMPHASIZE THE GROWING ROLE THAT
WOMEN PLAY IN CONSTRUCTION AND
THE TRADES BUILDING CAREERS. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PROCESS AND
STRIVE FOR MORE EQUITY IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL WOMEN IN
THE INDUSTRIES. I DO WANT TO
THANK THE WOMEN WHO HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN THE LEAD TO TWO IN THE
CONSTRUCTION FIELD AND ARE
PAVING THE WAY FOR SO MANY OTHER
WOMEN OUT THERE AND BE IN THE
ROLE MODELS THAT WE ALL NEED
TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SIMMONS QUIRK-SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
WHEN YOU THINK OF AN INDUSTRY
DOMINATED BY MEN CONSTRUCTION
MIGHT BE ONE OF THE FIRST THAT
COMES TO MIND. WE KNOW WE HAVE
ALL THOSE MEN THAT HAVE A STRONG
AND HARD WORKING BUT GUESS WHAT
WOMEN ARE TOO. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT LESS THAN 10% OF WOMEN ARE
IN THE CONSTRUCTION OR TRADES
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK IS A
TIME TO CELEBRATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WOMEN HAVE
MADE TO THE INDUSTRY AND
ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN TO CONSIDER
JOINING THE FILLED. UNTRADED
WOMEN TO PROJECT MANAGERS TO
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP. WOMEN ENJOY
A WIDE RANGE OF ROLES IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. HOWEVER
OUTDATED PERCEPTIONS STILL
EXISTS OF WHAT IT MEANS TO WORK
IN CONSTRUCTION NOT JUST AMONGST
WOMEN BUT ALSO AMONGST YOUNG
PEOPLE AS WELL. AS FOUR YEAR
DEGREES HAVE BEEN HEAVILY PUSHED
OVER THE YEARS. THE LAST DECADE
THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS AND
ADULTS PURSUING CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES CAREERS HAS
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY LEAVING
A SUBSTANTIAL SKILL GAP IN
AMERICA WE NEED THESE PEOPLE
JOINING IN THE CONSTRUCTION
FIELD TO BUILD OUR BRIDGES BUILD
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND BUILD
HOMES RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE GROWING DEMAND FOR THOSE WHO
WORK IN CONSTRUCTION HAS
PROVIDED GREATER OPPORTUNITY FOR
WOMEN TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
HIGHER SALARIES CAREER GROWTH
AND BENEFIT THAT THESE JOBS HAVE
TO OFFER IT'S TIME FOR MORE
WOMEN TO SEE THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES AS A VIABLE CAREER PATH
AND NORMALIZE THE PARTICIPATION
OF GIRLS AND YOUNG WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION ALSO AN
APPRENTICESHIP CHIPS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA.
AND MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
. COLLEAGUES I FEEL IMPELLED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS TODAY OF
COURSE ARE VERY OWN BODIES HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE BENEFITTED
FROM WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE.
THERE ARE WOMEN ARE CAPITAL
TODAY WHO ASSISTED US IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SWING SPACE
AN ASTONISHING PROJECT DONE IN
THIRTY TWO MONTHS DESPITE COVERT
. JUST THE ABILITY OF THOSE
FOLKS TO TRANSFORM THAT PARKING
LOT. INTO OUR PRESIDENCY THE
GOVERNMENT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THE GOVERNOR IS REALLY A
TESTAMENT TO THEIR SKILL. AND I
WANT TO SPEAK ALSO TO. I REALIZE
THERE'S TWO MOMENTS IN MY LIFE.
MY PRESENCE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WHERE THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES
ACTUALLY INTERVENE ONE SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT THE SKILL THE
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE ACQUIRES
INTERPRETER SHIP PROGRAMS THE
OTHER ONE SPEAKS TO THE
INDESCRIBABLE INGREDIENT OF
COMMITMENT TO EXCELLENCE THE
ABILITY ON A JOB YOU KNOW WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT THEN SEE A
WAY TO EMBELLISH IT. AND THEY'RE
BOTH TIED TO THIS BILL IS SO I
MOVED HERE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN I HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE TO
BUY A HOUSE CITY GOT PREGNANT
SHORTLY THEREAFTER IT DIDN'T
HAVE AIR CONDITIONING AND HODDLE
SACRAMENTAL. AND I MOVE CITY
HERE FOR THE MONTEREY PENINSULA
THIS CLIMB WAS A SHOCK WE
DECIDED TO ADD CENTRAL HEATING
HERE TO MY HOME. I NEEDED
UPGRADE THE PANEL. AND NOT A
WOMAN BUT HER DAD WILLIAM SMITH
WHO DIED MANY YEARS AGO MULTIPLE
MYELOMA WAS AN ELECTRICIAN HE
WAS ACTION THE PRESIDENT OF HIS
UNION ON THE MONTEREY PENINSULA
. AND BILL SMITH CAME UP TO
SACRAMENTO TO TAKE CARE HIS
DAUGHTER AND PUT IN THAT
UPGRADED PANEL TOOK CARE OF US
WE GOT THE AC IN. BUILDING THE
DUE COURSE OF TIME DIED DECADES
LATER WE REPLACE THAT UNIT.
EVERYTHING WAS SMOOTHLY WHAT
WHAT WAS DONE. MY WIFE SEDUCER
BROUGHT TO TEARS BECAUSE THE
PERSON DOING THE WORK CAME AND
KNOCKED ON THE DOOR. AND SAID TO
HER ALL DONE. WHO DID YOUR PANEL. SHE OF COURSE SAID MY DAD DID
THE PANEL. AND HE JUST REMARKED
UPON THE CALL QUALITY OF WORK IN
OUR LITTLE LEXICAL PANEL AT ONE
OH SIX TWO FOUR CHARDONNAY DRIVE
. WE JUST SAYS TO ME YOU KNOW
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IT'S SAFETY ON THE
JOB BUT IT'S WELL BEING FOR THE
PEOPLE RELY UPON IT. THE OTHER
STORE I JUST WANT TO SAY THIS IS
MORE ABOUT WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS BRING. DOWN ON THE FIRST
FLOOR WE HAVE THE OLD MUSEUM
ROOM TO NINETEEN OH SIX-
TREASURE'S OFFICE. IT'S GOT AN
ARCH WITH THE BEARS HAD IN IT
WHEN THAT DOORS OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. AND THAT ARCHES.
INDICATIVE OF CAST IRON. BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL ST PAUL.
THE ONE DOWN THERE IS ACTUALLY
MADE OUT OF WOOD BECAUSE THAT
WAS CHEAPER DURING THE
RESTORATION. BUT THE CREWS
WORKING ON OUR PROJECT INSTALLED
THAT. PUT IT UP LOOKED OUT AND
SAW THE WOOD GRAIN. REALIZED
THIS IS ABOUT. A LEGACY THAT I'M
CREATED FOR THE PEOPLE STAY THE
CALIFORNIA THEY YANKED IT OFF
THE WALL USE WHAT YOU AND I
WOULD CALL SPACKLE COVER THE
WHOLE THING UP. SANDED DOWN SEAL
IT AND NOW LOOKS LIKE. CANSTAR
WHICH JUST SAYS BEYOND THE SKILL
THERE IS THIS INEFFABLE QUALITY
THIS CREATIVITY THIS UNDERSTAND
THE TASK AT HAND. AND HOW TO
BRING IT HOME USING THEIR ART.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
CELEBRATE TODAY SKILL AND ART
FULLNESS IN THE EXECUTION. THANK
YOU MISS COOLEY MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YES MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO WANT TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO. WHO IS ALWAYS SEEN THAT THE
TRADES ARE A PATH TO SUCCESS FOR
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS I'VE SEEN.
HOW THESE THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS HAVE LED TO GREAT
PAYING JOBS THEY CAN PROVIDE FOR
PEOPLE'S FAMILIES- AND I I'M SO
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IS DONE REALLY
INVEST IN CTE PROGRAMS
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION. PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE GETTING INTO THESE TRADES
BUT AS I AS I'VE GONE AROUND TO
SOME OF THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS- IN THE STATE I'VE JUST
BEEN SO HARD TO SEE THE AMOUNT
OF WOMEN. WHO ARE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE MANY OF
THEM WE HAVE SOME OF THE GALLERY
WITH US TODAY YOU SEEN IN THE
BUILDING TODAY THEY'RE TRAPPED
THEY'RE GOING AROUND- THESE
WOMEN IN THE TRADES
ARE DOING AMAZING THINGS AND
THEY ARE WORTHY OF RECOGNITION I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO. THE
TRAIN PROGRAMS WHO HAVE MADE A
GREAT EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO
WOMEN AND GET MORE WOMEN INTO
THE TRADES- THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF PROGRESS MADE ON THAT FRONT
BUT THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
THAT WE STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO. WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THIS PATHWAY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I BELIEVE
ESPECIALLY TODAY WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION AND BUILDING TRADES
TODAY THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND I REGION AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION MISS
GARCIA YOU MAY CLOSE. ONE I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
WORDS TO DAY AND- WE HAVE A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITY OUT THERE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION AND TRADES FIELD
FOR MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES OUT
THERE AND SO EXCITED THAT WE'RE
BRINGING AWARENESS TO THIS ISSUE
TO BREAK BARRIERS AND CONTINUE
TO BREAK BARRIERS TO EQUITY. ON
INTO REALLY A MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILY OCCUPATION OUT THERE AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THE ONE I'VE VOTE. MAY OPEN
THE FIRST ROLE FOR ROLL CALL. I
MEAN PARK WATERS. THANK YOU MISS
C. MISTER C. IS REQUESTING THAT
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. CO
AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FORTY SIX
THIS IS CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL CLOSE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED OF WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. AND ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE SIXTY
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WHO ARE
HERE TODAY IN THE GALLERY WHO
ARE PAVING THE WAY FOR FUTURE
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION.
BACK ON THE FILE MEMBERS FILE
ITEMS FOR FIVE AND SIX ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD. PARMI SENATE
THIRD READING THAT SENATE THIRD
. IDMS FOUR THROUGH SEVEN ITEMS
FOUR THROUGH SEVEN. HOUSE AND
RETAIN. MEMBERS ANNOUNCEMENTS WE
HAVE SEVERAL COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THIS AFTERNOON. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE ONE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY PM IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY WILL MEET AT
TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM. FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. SELECT COMMITTEE ON URBAN
DEVELOPMENT TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS AT TWO THIRTY PM. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. AND MEMBERS
FOR THOSE WEARING THE COLORS OF
THE UKRAINIAN FLAG TODAY THERE
WILL BE A PHOTO TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR. IMMEDIATELY UPON
ADJOURNMENT TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE'S. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS
IN MEMORY. MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS MEMBERS I'D ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS. OFF OF
THE FLOOR. WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY MISS DAVIES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M HERE TODAY TO HONOR CHRIS
WALLACE WHO SADLY LOST HIS
BATTLE WITH CANCER ON JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CHRIS WAS A DEVOTED HUSBAND
LOVING FATHER TO HIS TWO
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS AND A FRIEND TO
EVERYONE HE MET. CHRIS WAS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT WHO
SERVED MANY ORANGE COUNTY
ASSEMBLY OFFICES THE CITY OF
IRVINE AND LASTLY THE THIRTY
NINTH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
CHRIS WAS A DILIGENT WORKER AND
ALWAYS BROUGHT OUT THE BEST IN
EVERYONE CHRIS WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS KINDNESS
SENSE OF HUMOR AND HIS BEAUTIFUL
CHARISMA WE WILL ALL MISS CHRIS
TERRIBLY BUT ITS LEGACY WILL
REMAIN ETERNAL AND ALL OF OUR
HEARTS TODAY WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF CHRIS WALLACE. THANK
YOU MISS DAVIS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANS IN MEMORY THANK YOU
SPEAKERS AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
DAY I RISE UP TO A JONES IN THE
MEMORY OFF- MISTER RALPH ON. RON
WAS OF REGARDED AS AN EXEMPLARY
FIGURE AS A ONE OF THE MOST OF
SUCCESS FOR KOREAN AMERICAN
ACTORS. AS A NOTABLE KOREAN
AMERICAN ROTH SISTER OF THE
VIDEO AND THE IN THE SECOND
WORLD WAR. ENLISTING IN THE NAVY
IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. RAFA
PURSUED THE ACTING AFTER
RETURNING OFF FROM WERE WITH
HIS- FIRST A FUME BEING THE
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE. WARAR FILM
BATTLES SUCKERS WHICH HE
FOLLOWED UP A YEAR LATER
APPEARING ALONGSIDE THE PRESTON
ONE REAGAN IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR SO PRISONER OF WAR. OTTAWA
SUN ADDED THE SUPPORT ROLE- FOR
KOREAN INDEPENDENCE BEING
INSPIRED THE BY HIS FATHER A
RENOWNED THE KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE. ACTIVISTS ARE
CLOSE ON AND TOM HOLE AND UP BUT
DISSIPATED THE IN NUMEROUS OF
KOREAN CULTURAL EVENTS INCLUDING
MARCH FIRST AND THE LIBERATION
DAY CELEBRATION SO THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE. WRONGFUL WENT ON TO
TEACH THIS EDUCATION IN LOSS AND
A BEGINNING IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES UP BEFORE RETURNING TO
RUN HIS A FAMILY RESTAURANT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. ROTH ONCE
MORE RETURNED TO ACTING IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT END UP
BROUGHT ABOUT THE IS SO MOST A
WELL KNOWN RULE RULE IN THE CITY
REDUCE THE GOLDEN GOPHERS AND-
HIS OF CAREER DEFINING AND A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED THE ROLE.
AS THE ASYLUM BUT THE WISE TRÊN
IN THE SERIES- NEW GORE. OR IN
AMERICANS CECILIA ON AS A
PIONEER OF FOR THE- ESTEEM OF
ALL KOREAN AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
THE U. S. A. IT IS SO TRUE ARE
NOT TO A JONES IN A MEMORY OF-
RAFI ON. ON TODAY'S SESSION AS
WELL HE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
HUSBAND FATHER AND THE LEADER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR CHOI AND
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY YEAH I CONTINUE- TO ASK-
WOULD JOIN THIS SESSION IN
MEMORY OF- AND WITH THE A GOOD
THE- CONSTITUENT A AND MY
DISTRICT- MISTER GEORGIA OF ROOM
LAUREUS- WHO HAPPENS TO BE
FATHER ABA KATHY OF LOWRY'S SAW.
A UP CLOSE FRIEND- AND THEN ALSO
A COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE CITY OF
ALL ORANGE. GEORGIA WAS A LONG
TIME AND NOT ACTIVE A RESTAURANT
IN THE CITY OF ROCK ORANGE ON
APRIL SEVENTEENTH AND NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX IN THE SMALL MOUNTAIN
VILLAGE. ALL OF- CORREA. GREASE
UPON GRADUATING HIS- A HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR HE
ENROLLED TO INDIA ROYAL I
HELLENIC AIRFORCE ACADEMY AFTER
FINISHING HIS- SERVICE- WOULD
YOU MEN WENT TO ATHENS SO
LOOKING FOR WORK AND- OPENED A
CAFE IN- LOU LOU LAW ONE OF THE
CITY'S AS ABOVE SO AND- RAN IT
FOR TWO YEARS NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE- GEORGE MOVED TO ACROSS THE
ATLANTIC TO MONTREAL N. DOT
AFTER. A DECADE OF. AFTER DECADE
. OF THE FAMILY TO ILLINOIS
GEORGE FOUNDER GREAT THE
CONFLICT- IN BEING AROUND ALL ON
ABUNDANCE OF FOOD. I HAVING
GROWN UP OUT WITH THIS GAS OF
SCARCITY OF IT THE WORKING AT
THE US SUPERMARKETS- BUTCHER
SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS WHILE IN
ILLINOIS HE OPENED HIS OWN
RESTAURANT- IN ROCK ISLAND. IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES THE
FAMILY MOVED TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. GEORGIA LOVE TO
VOLUNTEER AT THE GREEK FESTIVAL
SO AND THE WORK AS A CHEF AT THE
GREEK CAPS. FEEDING ALL THOSE
WELL SO GEORGE'S PASSION ID LOVE
TO SEE PEOPLE SATISFIED THE AND
TAKEN CARE OF. MANY TIMES SO IN
ALL OF HIS SO RESTAURANTS
THROUGHOUT THE. THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS. HE FED HUNGRY PIT.
ATTEMPTING NOPE. GEORGE A
DEVOTED A HOST WHO IS SO WHY FOR
FULL OF SIX YEARS AND IS A
SURVIVOR BY HIS WIFE MARIA IS
SUCH CHILDREN PERIANDER KATHY IS
A SEMINAL- PANEL PAPPAS AND
HISTOGRAM CHILDREN AREA AND-
ANNA DIOP. WE WILL MISS GEORGIA
TOUGH LARA'S AND A COMMAND HIM
FOR HIS OF MANY YEARS OF A
SERVICE SO WOBBLE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR CHOI
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH
EIGHTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY MARCH NINTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY MARCH THE TENTH
FLOOR SESSION. IS AT NINE AM ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
OR FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN IS
REYES MOVES AND MISS. MISS
DAVIES SECONDS THAT IS HOUSE
INJURED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH THE
TENTH AT NINE AM WE ARE TURNED.